you are a whistleblower you went through
you and and your colleagues went through
official channels um was that a wise
decision well you know since I always
viewed the United States as we the guys
who had the white hats you know I
thought gee well you know if the people
downtown and different in different
congressional committees knew about this
they would they would start to fulfill
their oath of office to protect and
defend the Constitution and would do the
right thing and if not there then
perhaps through the IJ's and so on or
through the courts we could get that
done so we kept trying for the better
part of seven years to to make that
known to try to get the government to
start to address some of its criminal
activity right but instead they went the
other way and they to the dark side
basically doing retroactive immunity for
the crimes for the telecoms that the
crimes that they were committing and
basically keeping everything else secret
so nobody could show anything in court
it was done with a secret court under
secret interpretations of laws and so on
I mean this is this is all the secret
government well let's talk about Edward
Snowden because he you know and there's
a host of questions because he is
clearly building on you know on the
actions or he learned from your
experience and Apple like you experience
it was he wise not to go through
official channels official channels
didn't work I mean they just simply
don't work
you